mein Kind versprich immer brav zu sein
geh nicht in den Wald und schon gar
nicht allein sei stets Gehorsam und hö
was wir sagen geh nicht in den Wald denn
dort wird er dich jagen geh nicht in den
Wald denn dort droht Gefahr vom stup dem
Werwolf vom
teufelgar mit Zähnen so spitz mit Augen
voll Lust er reißt dir dein zuckendes
Herz aus der Brust dein Hirn wird
erfressen dein blutwetter saufen bis
nichts von dir bleibt als ein
Knochenhaufen drum denk dran stets brav
und gehorsam zu sein und nun gute Nacht
mein Kind Schlaf schnell
ein
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hi mein lieber Scholli was war das
denn ist dem Kim jetzt final die
Sicherung durchgebrannt ich würde sagen
nein na ja ich dachte bei uns kommt die
Poesie normalerweise ein bisschen kurz
und deswegen dachte ich mir fange ich
mal mit einem kleinen Gedicht an oder
eher ein Schlaflied war das ja wobei man
nicht weiß wie gut die lieben Kinder
nach sowas dann schlafen na ja ich meine
auch nicht schlimmer als die Märchen der
Gebrüder Grimm das Gedicht habe ich
übrigens aus einem anderen Podcast und
der heißt Ritter Tod und Teufel von
wakeworth so eine Art True Crime im
Mittelalter und die fangen jede Folge
mit so einem Gedicht an und jetzt zum
Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme ist der
Podcast noch gar nicht erschienen aber
wir konnten schon mal reinhören na das
schöne ist wir sind mit unserer Episode
über Peter Stupp den Werwolf von
bettburg bei Köln auf jeden Fall
schneller als Ritter Tod und Teufel sehr
gut das hö ich gern herzlich willkommen
dann übrigens Liebe Zuhörerin und
Zuhörer zu Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Stefan Netzeband und ich bin Mirko
Kasimir und vielleicht fragt ihr euch so
langsam was hier eigentlich los ist
keine Sorge uns geht's gut unser Thema
heute ein
Werwolf wir sind nicht völlig abgedreht
wir sind auch kein Fantasy Podcast
geworden oder nee nee nee keine Sorge
wir bleiben True Crime und es geht auch
heute um einen echten Kriminalfall bzw
gleich eine ganze Reihe davon die Frage
ist ob es auch um einen echten Werwolf
geht ja wir halten uns da in unserer
Einschätzung eines Falles ja oft an das
was die Gerichte für wahr befunden haben
wenn wir das diesmal auch machen würden
dann müssten wir sagen ja es geht um
einen echten Werwolf einen
Gestaltwandler um einen Mann der sich in
einen Wolf verwandeln konnte und in
dieser Form die schrecklichsten
denkbaren Verbrechen verübte also
Kindermord Vergewaltigung Kannibalismus
Inzest Teufelsanbetung t da kam
ordentlich was zusammen und wir sind
natürlich keine Juristen und wir waren
weder bei den Taten noch bei der
Verhandlung dabei aber wir maßen uns
jetzt trotzdem mal ganz frech an die
Richtigkeit dieses Urteils zumindest was
den werwolfpart angeht in Frage zu
stellen und das ganze Gericht gleich mit
denn wir gehen heute zurück in die Zeit
der Hexen Prozesse genauer müsste man
sagen der Hexen und
zaubererpzesse die große Mehrheit der
Opfer sind natürlich Frauen gewesen
denen Hexerei schadzauber Unzucht mit
dem Teufel und Flüge auf dem Hexenbesen
vorgeworfen werden aber auch Männer sind
nicht sicher vor Anklage wegen Zauberei
und
Teufelsanbetung im Jahr 1486 wird das
Buch maleus malefikarum der berühmt
berüchtigte Hexenhammer des Dominikaners
Heinrich kamer erstmals gedruckt zwar
wird es nie offiziell von der Kirche
anerkannt es ist auch nicht der Beginn
der Hexenverfolgung aber es spielt als
früher Bestseller eine wichtige Rolle
bei der Ausbreitung dieser Praxis nach
der Veröffentlichung steigt die Zahl der
Prozesse gegen angebliche Hexen und
Zauberer stark an ja und man muss sagen
die damalige Situation in Europa und
Deutschland die begünstigt das natürlich
im 15 Jahrhundert beginnt die Kleine
Eiszeit es kommt zu kalten Sommern
eisigen Wintern zu Missernten und Hunger
die Pest sucht Deutschland Heim die
Menschen suchen nach einer Erklärung für
all das Unglück Geschichten von Frauen
und Männern die mit dem Teufel und
seinen Dämonen im Bunde stehen die
bieten sich da geradezu an es ist auch
die Zeit der politischen und
technologischen Umbrüche um 1450 hat
Gutenberg den modernen Buchdruck
erfunden ohneem der Hexenhammer gar
nicht solche Breitung hätte finden
können und ohne den Luthers Reformation
sicherlich nicht so schnell so
erfolgreich gewesen wäre mit allen
Konsequenzen die das hatte bis hin zur
Gegenreformation zum Bauernkrieg und
schließlich zum 30jährigen Krieg
interessante Zeiten damals im Sinne
dieses chinesischen Fluches mögest du in
interessanten Zeiten leben du hast
bösartige Seiten manchmal aber irgendwie
interessant wie heute auch eigentlich
oder Klimawandel Pandemien neue Medien
die alles durcheinander wirbeln Krieg na
ja trotzdem nicht ganz dasselbe zum
Glück ist ja z.B die Medizin ein ganzes
Stück weiter und um die Pest müssen wir
uns zum Glück auch keine Sorgen mehr
machen na ja dafür gibt's heutzutage
andere Schrecken Stichwort Atombomben
und so weiter aber jetzt schweifen wir
ein bisschen zu weit ab zurück zum
Beginn des 16 Jahrhunderts da wird in
der Nähe von Köln Peter Stub geboren
über sein Leben ist nur sehr wenig
bekannt dafür kennen wir alle
schrecklichen Details seines Todes aber
merco sorry erzähl erstmal weiter wir
kennen das Geburtsdatum nicht die
Angaben dazu reichen von
1525 bis
1535 wir wissen nicht sicher ob sein
Geburtsort betburg oder eprat war wir
kennen nicht einmal seinen richtigen
Nachnamen Peter Stub stumpf Stubbe
Stübbe es gibt zahllose Varianten
wahrscheinlich rüt der Name daher dass
er seine linke Hand bei einem Unfall
verloren hat wenn es denn ein Unfall war
wenn es denn ein Unfall war vermutlich
war Peter Bauer vielleicht auch Schäfer
und höchstwahrscheinlich ein Protestant
und damit ein Außenseiter im
katholischen Rheinland man geht davon
aus dass er zum Zeitpunkt der fraglichen
Ereignisse witwa war und eine
unverheiratete Tochter hatte man ist
sich heute ziemlich sicher dass dieser
wie auch immer existiert hat und dass er
tatsächlich verhaftet verurteilt und
hingerichtet wurde wie viel vom Rest der
ganzen Geschichte war ist das lässt sich
schlicht nicht mehr seriös beantworten
vielleicht erzählen wir die Geschichte
also am besten so wie sie sich Peter
Stups Zeitgenossen dargestellt haben
soll
Oktober
1589 schon wieder hat der Wolf ein Schaf
gerissen und grausam verstümmelt die
Bauern von sind verzweifelt Kinder
trauen sich schon lange nicht mehr in
den Wald aus Angst vor dem Raubtier das
in den Erzählungen die die Runde machen
immer größer und blutrünstiger wird ein
Monster mit glühenden vom Mordlust
sprühenden Augen der Leibhaftige in
Tiergestalt doch diesmal werden sie es
ihm zeigen die Männer von betedburg
gehen auf die Jagd und sie haben Erfolg
die Hunde treiben den Wolf vor sich her
einer Dogge gelingt es mit den Zähnen
ein Bein des Wolfes zu packen doch der
reißt sich los Blut spritzt aus einer
Wunde und der verschwindet in
undurchdringlich scheinendem
Gebüsch dort sitzt er in der Falle als
die Männer sein Versteck erreichen rufen
Sie die Hunde
[Musik]
zurück es raschelt Zweige knacken
Blätter zittern die Bauern heben die
Heugabeln und Knüppel und was Sie sonst
noch als Waffen mitgebracht haben und
aus dem Gehölz bricht ein
Mann Hilfe ruft er so helft mir doch der
Wolf hat mich
angefallen an seiner Wade klafft eine
lange blutende Wunde vor den verdutzten
Dorfbewohnern steht Peter einer von
ihnen wenn auch nicht wohl gelitten in
der Gemeinschaft schon lange gibt es
Gerüchte um sein zurückgezogenes Leben
seine unverheiratete Tochter die
Geliebte und den Sohn den schon so lange
niemand mehr gesehen
hat der Wolf aber der ist verschwunden
es gibt nur eine Erklärung peter und der
Wolf sind ein und
derselbe der Mann wird verhaftet und der
Zauberei
angeklagt es gibt noch mindestens eine
andere weit verbreitete Version der
Verhaftung des Werwolfs von betedburg
demnach habe ein Bauer oder Schäfer den
Wolf bei m Angriff auf seine Herde
überrascht und ihm mit einem Schwert die
Linke Vorderpfote abgeschlagen als er
kurz darauf den Peter besucht fehlt ihm
die linke Hand na ja wie auch immer
Peter stupf gesteht schnell er
praktiziere seit seinem zw lebensjahr
also seit gut 50 Jahren schwarze Magie
und sei mit dem Teufel im Bunde dieser
habe ihm einen Gürtel aus Wolfsfell
geschenkt und sobald er diesen umlegt
verwandelt er sich in einen Wolf den
Gürtel so sagt er hat er weggeworfen
bevor er sich seinen Verfolgern stellte
die Suche nach diesem Beweisstück bleibt
allerdings erfolglos kein zaubergürtel
nirgends aber die Ankläger wissen sich
zu helfen dass das Beweisstück
verschwunden ist das ist für sie der
Beweis dass hier der Teufel am Werk ist
denn wer sonst hätte den Gürtel
verschwinden lassen sollen mhm
bestechende Logik und außerdem hat man
ja sowieso das Geständnis in der Gestalt
eines Wolfes habe er nicht nur Schafe
gerissen immer grausiger werden die
Taten der er sich selbst
bezichtigt was vielleicht möglicherweise
auch ein bisschen damit zu tun haben
könnte dass man ihn auf die Streckbank
spannt um seinem Mitteilungsdrang auf
die Sprünge zu helfen so lief es auf
jeden Fall ja bei den meisten Prozessen
im Gefolge des Hexenhammers ab die
Rechtssprechung sah vor dass niemand
ohne ein Geständnis verurteilt werden
kann also musste um jeden Preis ein
Geständnis beschafft werden viele Opfer
wurden wahrscheinlich gar nicht wirklich
gefoltert sondern taten alles um Ihre
Ankläger schon vorher zufrieden zu
stellen um eben dieser Folter zu
entgehen der Tod auf dem Scheiterhaufen
auf dem Rad oder am geen der erschien im
Vergleich zu endlosen Torturen in der
Folterkammer tatsächlich weniger schlimm
düstere Zeiten ganz nach dem Motto
lieber ein Ende mit Schrecken als ein
Schrecken ohne Ende zumal ihnen
sicherlich bewusst war dass sie
schließlich doch dem Henker gegenüber
treten würden Peter Stub gesteht also
grauenhafte Verbrechen über 20 Jahre
hinweg soll er in Wolfsgestalt getötet
haben 13 Kinder habe er gerissen und
ihre Herzen gefressen heiß und roh wie
es in einem der Flugblätter heißt die
später über diesen Fall verbreitet
werden also im Prinzip ein bisschen wie
die Zeitung von heute einer von ihnen
sei sogar sein eigener Sohn gewesen er
habe ihn innig geliebt aber eines Tages
habe der Blutdurst ihn übermannt Peter
nimmt seinen Sohn mit in den Wald
vollzieht die Verwandlung zum Wolf und
tötet ihn dann frisst er das Gehirn
seines
Sohnes unter den Opfern sind so lautet
zumindest das Geständnis auch zwei
schwangere Frauen er tötet sie dann
reißt er ihren Bauch auf und verschlingt
ihre ungeborenen Babys noch immer nicht
genug es kommen noch weitere
Anklagepunkte dazu bzw angebliche
Geständnisse unter anderem Inzest mit
der Tochter die Tötung unzähliger
Weidetiere und natürlich die ganze Sache
mit der schwarzen Magie und dem Pakt mit
dem Teufel inklusive Sex mit einem
sukubus also einem weiblichen
Dämon am 28 Oktober
1589 verkündet ein Tribunal das
Urteil Peter Stubbe der Hauptschuldige
wird zum zerschlagen durch einen Rad und
zum Zerreißen seines Fleisches
verurteilt an zehn verschiedenen Stellen
mit einer heißen Zange so dass es vom
Knochen getrennt wird dann sollen seine
Beine und Arme mit Holzstöcken oder
Hämmern gebrochen werden dann soll er
enthauptet und schließlich verbrannt
werden bis nichts als Asche übrig bleibt
Stubs Tochter und seine Geliebte werden
als komplizinen ebenfalls zum Tode
verurteilt
also was die Strafen angeht von allem zu
viiel wie eine bestimmte Eissorte
heutzutage wirbt die Hinrichtung am 31
Oktober 1589 in bettburg zieht auf jeden
Fall und verständlicherweise zahlreiche
Schaulustige an die beiden Verurteilten
Frauen werden an Pfähle gebunden
ausgepeitscht und schließlich erwirkt
und dann ist Peter stupf an der Reihe
alles geschieht wie im Urteil festgelegt
man legt ihn auf ein Rat und reißt mit
rotglühender Zange an zehn Stellen
seines Körpers Haut und Fleisch von den
Knochen anschließend zertrümmert der
Henker mit der stumpfen Seite einer Axt
die Arme und Beine des Verurteilten und
bindet ihn auf das Rad dann schlägt er
ihm Hände und Füße ab es wirkt fast
schon wie ein Gnadenakt dass er ihm
schließlich mit einem letzten Streich
den Kopf vom Rumpf trennt und das
schreckliche leiden damit beendet und
zur Abschreckung pflanzt man den Kopf
auf eine Stange die man zusammen mit dem
Rad und einer wolfsfigur in btburg
aufstellt die Hinrichtung von Peter
Stupp gilt als eine der grausamsten
ihrer Zeit in Deutschland und wir müssen
jetzt natürlich noch mal darüber
sprechen wie viel denn wohl an dieser
ganzen Geschichte wahr ist tja und da
sind wir leider auf Spekulationen
angewiesen zwei Sachen kann man
allerdings mit einiger Sicherheit sagen
erstens es gab das Geständnis es gab das
Urteil und es gab die darauffolgende
Hinrichtung und zweitens Peter Stub
konnte sich nicht wirklich in einen Wolf
verwandeln alles weitere verschwindet im
Nebel der Geschichte und sollte es
Gerichtsakten gegeben haben damals so
verbrannten sie leider im 30-jährigen
Krieg in bettburg ebrat das ist ja der
vermutete Geburtsort von Peter Stupp der
verschwand gleich ganz von der Landkarte
wenn auch erst
1963 als er nämlich dem Tagebau
gartzweiler weichen musste und als
neuprat an anderer Stelle wieder
gegründet wurde die meisten Quellen
stammen zudem nicht einmal aus
Deutschland sondern sind größtenteils
Flugblätter die in England über den Fall
verbreitet wurden es gibt ein paar
Theorien was sich tatsächlich abgespielt
haben könnte eine besagt dass es in
dieser Zeit eine wolfsplage in der
Gegend gab dass immer wieder Tiere auf
der Weide gerissen wurden vielleicht war
Peter stupf ohnehin unbeliebt vielleicht
gab es Gerüchte über Inzest in seinem
Haus vielleicht macht ihn auch zur
zielschreibe dass er als Protestant in
einer katholischen Gegend lebte tja und
wer weiß vielleicht gab es tatsächlich
einen Vorfall bei dem ein Wolf verwundet
wurde und blöderweise verletzte sich
stup um dieselbe Zeit herum an einer
dazu passenden Stelle seines Körpers
alles möglich den Rest besorgenten dann
ein paar besorgte Bürger wie man sie
heute nennt die sich an die Obrigkeit
wanden und schließlich dann die
Streckbank oder es steckt mehr dahinter
was wenn nicht nur Weidetiere starben
sondern tatsächlich immer wieder Kinder
und schwangere Frauen verschwanden oder
schrecklich zugerichtet aufgefunden
wurden heutzutage würden wir sofort
einen Serienmörder vermuten oder
übrigens auch als Macher und Hörer
dieses Podcasts aber dieses Konzept das
gab es damals noch gar nicht die Idee
dass ein scheinbar ganz normal Mensch
ein Nachbar ein Verwandter aus sich
heraus so schreckliche Dinge tun könnte
die schien damals absurd das Böse musste
immer von außen kommen von marodierenden
Söldnern oder im Wald versteckt lebenden
Räubern da hatte jeder schon gehört dass
aber einer von ihnen so sehr unter
seines Gleichen wütete das musste
bedeuten dass der Teufel im Spiel war es
gab damals keine andere Erklärung wenn
wir annehmen dass es diese Morde
tatsächlich gab wissen wir freilich
immer noch nicht ob der Richtige dafür
bestraft wurde denn wie schon gesagt die
Folter war kein Instrument der
Wahrheitsfindung sie sorgte nur dafür
dass Geständnisse produziert wurden die
keinerlei Wert hatten außer natürlich
für die Gerichte die damit ihre Fälle
als gelöst abschließen und jemanden
verurteilen konnten es gibt noch eine
dritte oftgörte Theorie vielleicht war
Peter Stub das Opfer einer politisch
religiösen Intrige der Prozess fällt in
die Zeit der Gegenreformation gerade ein
Jahr zuvor ist der sogenannte
trugsesssische Krieg auch der
kölnerkrieg genannt zu Ende gegangen
katholische Truppen hatten den Versuch
vereitelt das erststift Köln in ein
protestantisches Herzogtum zu verwandeln
vielleicht so meinen manche ging es beim
Prozess und bei der grausamen
öffentlichen Hinrichtung weniger um die
Warnung sich auf keinen Fall mit dem
Teufel einzulassen sondern sich gar
nicht erst mit den Protestanten
einzulassen die genau des Teufels waren
wie Hexen und
Werwölfe alles Spekulation wie gesagt
der Tod des Peter Stub aber war real der
Hexenhammer war real die Hexenprozesse
und das Leiden der Opfer waren real der
Fall des Werwolfs von bettburg schlug in
seiner Zeit wirklich hohe Wellen wurde
in ganz Europa bekannt und fachte die
Feuer der Inquisition weiter an und in
der Gegend um Köln heißt der Werwolf bis
heute stüpp okay und um hier nicht ganz
so düster zu enden noch ein kleiner fun
fact obwohl fun hier im Zusammenhang mit
dieser Geschichte nicht wirklich die
allerbeste Wortwahl ist der eine oder
die andere hat sich vielleicht gewundert
dass sich der Werwolf mit Hilfe eines
Gürtels verwandelt hat den er nach
Belieben umlegen und abnehmen konnte
also fast wie so ein modernes
elektronisches Gadget das irgendwelche
Superkräfte verleiht und darum wusste
ich auch gleich dass das Urteil gar
nicht stimmen kann denn natürlich weiß
jeder gebildete Mensch dass man für die
Verwandlung zu einem Werwolf Vollmond
braucht ich weiß nicht ja komm Mirko war
natürlich ein Witz jedenfalls ist diese
ganze vollmondgeschichte wohl eine
Erfindung der Romantiker die hatten das
nicht so mit teufelsbünden und Zauberei
da musste alles mystisch düster und eben
auch ein bisschen romantisch sein ja ja
so sind sie eben die Romantiker für
unsere Geschichte über den Werwolf von
betbruck haben wir unter anderem Artikel
der Welt des stern und des National
Geographic verwendet sehr hilfreich
waren auch die Seiten ancient-
origins.de und
elma-lori.de sowie der schon erwähnte
aber noch nicht veröffentlichte Podcast
Ritter Tod und Teufel von
wakeworth danke fürs Zuhören hört uns
weiter und empfehlt uns gerne weiter und
passt auf Euch auf vielleicht ist schon
bald wieder Vollmond und damit bis zum
nächsten mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan
dir hat diese Folge von Tat Deutschland
gefallen du bekommst von True Crime
einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt in
unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca Rusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Hermann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland